[Music]
what if we all just sing at the same
time yeah okay oh
that's 21st century doing something
means
we brought together seven kanye fans i
am a kanye fan i'm a kanye fan i'm a
kanye fan i'm a kanye fan i'm a kanye
fan i'm a kanye fan i'm a kanye fan 100
one is a life if the group discovers who
the liar is they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize who is the odd one out
so we just all introduce ourselves say
our favorite song i'm susie favorite
song is lost in the world my name is jay
bruce my favorite song is bittersweet
poetry from graduation you see that
right okay okay okay my name's alex my
favorite song is amazing my name is
chase and my favorite song is bound two
my name is carrie and my favorite song
is never let me down my name is ty my
favorite song is famous my name is jack
and my favorite song is saint papa
what's everyone's favorite album though
i wear it on my chest
right here it's my beautiful dark
twisted fantasy yeah absolutely my
favorite song for sure
for me that's good i'll go with you with
that yeah
when ty said his favorite song jack was
like oh same and i was like ah that's
kind of that's kind of soft any of you
guys seen him in concert unfortunately
twice
pablo bye for pablo jesus
my dad was doing security at the time
and so he was letting me go under the
stage
yeah it was it was a spot i saw him at
the the meadows music festival where he
left for the kim kardashian
i'm sorry this is a family emergency i
have to stop showing oh you know
i was like
40 minutes of just heaven and then it
was like wow my money is gone
why did you rob me more than you've
already robbed me but you had the
experience everybody else just watched
it on tmz that was part of keeping up
with the kardashians episodes pretty
cool
[Music]
i voted for alex just because she was a
little bit more on the quiet side the
first round and didn't really get
involved but i guess neither did i so i
can't really say much
she was a little bit too enthusiastic
for me which made me suspect that maybe
she has something to hide
she stood out because she didn't stand
out
[Music]
[Applause]
good luck guys
i only got to say like four words on
camera and i think i just said saint
pablo in my name and then i was voted
out
how do you defend him like you know
throughout just being a kanye fan like
what like what is your moment i think
everyone thinks that he means exactly
what he says but i think that he just
has a really difficult time articulating
himself there would be no travis scott
there would be none of these like
influential people without him so it's
like hard to like do away with him even
like when he does like problematic
things i'm just going to let him do what
he does i'm going my own business i
separate him from fashion and music to
his little politics and stuff he's
having like a really human journey
through everything especially since he's
being so vocal about what he's going
through with like being bipolar i don't
think that's easy i do admire him for
like trying to articulate it in the way
that he does not in the way that society
says oh this is how you're supposed to
behave what was like everyone's pivotal
moment that they knew they were a kanye
west fan i grew up listening to kanye
west it was like my mom would put it on
when we clean and stuff what would you
put on like what oh college dropout like
champion come on we know yeah similar
experience my mom put me on kanye we
when tower
we would go like every other weekend and
she picked up late registration i didn't
know who he was i was a kid i was really
young she puts him on i'm like i heard
him say him and i was like
her responses seem to like frame around
just old kanye not so much new kanye my
pivotal moment that kind of stuck with
me was i was watching like mtv music
videos and just saw this guy
mumbling through the wire like he said
we kind of grew up together because
every time you drop something you just
kind of like you know we're there with
him throughout all the journey and not
to be mean but she seemed very plain
very
pacsun kanye fan i didn't really care
about music in general until like senior
year of high school i just remember like
the life of pablo was just about to drop
and i was just like so curious about it
because i was reading the wikipedia page
about how it was like three pablos it
was escobar
yeah picasso i don't know it's just such
a different environment he said like the
three pablos and then he didn't know the
third pablo i was like that's really sus
shoot my cousin put me on to kanye when
i was like younger and then that's when
i started to like really develop my like
love for kanye not saying that i'm a
stan i don't know man you have a tattoo
of them
got the angels right here too can we see
the angels are we allowed to see the
angels
oh wow
that's not from etsy
[Music]
she was the least involved in my
personal opinion carrie didn't really
give me like a reassurance that she was
a true kanye fan
[Music]
carrie was good i think she was playing
a tactic of introducing a question but
then observing
[Music]
[Applause]
i wasn't super
peppy i think i was really just
listening and observing and maybe they
took that as a sign of some type of
concealment if everyone feels confident
that you already caught them all you can
end the game now but if the majority has
doubt the game will continue please
raise your hand if you want to continue
playing the game
that's majority starting now for every
time all of you vote out someone that is
not the mole the total prize money will
be reduced
in this round you will choose a kanye
song and finish each other's lyrics one
by one are we allowed to say the curse
words in this oh yeah that's what i was
like i was gonna do it regardless
this is a pretty notable song on the
album all right so we'll just go down
the line now if i this model and
she just bleached her apple and imma get
bleach on my t-shirt and i almost think
i'm like oh
i was fine when i let her we was hot and
dry becca she get under your skin if you
let her i don't want them
i met this girl when i was three years
old
and what i loved moshe got so much sauce
okay okay honestly i got really nervous
and then i just forgot completely
everything i feel like we all know
different likes
what about a more miscellaneous song
from that album made it sound always
wacky
boy
twisted fiction
children
listen
oh yeah
when a real n word holds you down what
are you supposed to do drown this man
right here
i don't know where i don't know where
we're going from there
alex chose power for us to kind of
bounce back and forth which that's like
a very popular song like this could be
one that kind of everybody can show up
to okay wait what if we all just sing at
the same time yeah okay oh i'm moving in
the 21st century
[Music]
he kind of threw me for a loop just
because he couldn't really like come up
with anything maybe you stopped being a
kanye fan after the time you had those
tattoos done i guess every superhero has
needed music
to have all that power the clock's
ticking i just count the hours
i don't think we got any closer to
guessing anyone seemed like a detour on
the investigation it was like if
scooby-doo had a musical episode
we have a tie
it's a five-way tie what
we wrote
we're like who is it we're all spiders
one minute try to figure out who the
mole is we all love him but let's be a
little critical um worst thing he's ever
said slavery was a choice yeah 100
another one that he said was he went on
air for the red cross thing for
hurricane katrina said george bush
doesn't care about black people when he
was at the concert and the guy was in
the wheelchair that one would i can't
say what you already said yeah yeah the
red hat thing him running for president
under like a republican
we can really like do it but
yeah
uh i mean that houseway stuff
i don't know i mean he had that
interview where he was like you know
going off this way yeah yeah do it
yourself
sway that wasn't that bad that wasn't
that
i'm like okay man i can't i can't keep
defending you in these streets
i thought he was like very charismatic
and he like came in like so excited alex
was wearing nike sneakers so i was like
okay that's pretty sucks
i love you guys
to be honest i don't i don't really know
why they eliminated me
please raise your hand if you want to
continue playing the game
okay the game will end now if the lights
turn green that means you have voted out
the mole and you win if the lights turn
red that means the mole is still in the
box and you
lose
damn
those real tattoos i'm surprised i
thought we got them all out will the
fake kanye fan please step forward and
reveal yourself in three
two
[Music]
one i voted for it i appreciate that
i was surprised only because we had all
sung together i guess at the end of the
day the bag talks and she broke my heart
bro it was right in front of us the
whole time
i know nike's on that should be like
kind of a dead giveaway because like
kanye's so against like nike and whatnot
that's like going into costco with like
a sam's club card i am no longer a kanye
fan i believe that when you have a
successful platform and influence it's
your responsibility to be mindful of
your actions and what it is that you're
saying so i could no longer be a fan
because of that it makes sense you can
go from being a kanye lover to a hater
really quick because of how volatile his
personality is i'm a black creative and
to see a black creative who deals with
mental health issues reach this level of
prominence and success will keep me
rooted as a kanye fan and i feel like
seeing him in that context is what a
real fan of him is and of his legacy and
his persona we want to thank you all for
participating and give you all a gift
these are odd one out bags we're all
winners today
we're gonna sport this
good job alex thanks guys
[Music]